[Music]
we've talked a lot about the physical
aspects of coronavirus how equally
important though we know is the mental
and emotional impact of the outbreak
I do national poll shows 53% of
Americans are worried about a family
member getting infected 60% believe the
worst is yet to come
80% believe daily life will change even
if ever so slightly dr. Amy Compton
Phillips executive vice president of
Providence st. Joseph's Hospital Health
System in Washington State has been on a
panel now we're going to just pull you
out of it because you've seen people in
panic mode you're a doctor and now
you've got an outbreak talk to me about
the fear that people are kind of just
rolling with in their daily lives about
this fear is real I mean we've gone from
having a booming economy that people are
going about their daily lives and all
the sudden the breaks are put on and
we're asking people to completely change
everything because of some unknown
unseen virus circulating around the
community and so that's a frightening
thing and the most important thing we
can do in health care and leadership and
government is to be consistent be honest
before thright and help people prepare
rather than panic and I think that's
that right now is our job is to say we
can actually do something about it and
that's why we're asking you to stay home
we don't want to see those steep curves
like you've seen in Iran and Italy we
want to flatten that curve out and make
sure that we keep people safe by keeping
them apart how do we talk to our
children doctor the same kind of thing
you know the good news that our kids are
safe because children seem to not get
affected so much which is a wonderful
thing we can tell them that it won't
affect them but that they're staying
away from others they're staying away
from their friends because we don't
bring them with them to bring germs to
their family and to their grandparents
and to their friends and so helping them
understand why it is where we're keeping
them away from school I think is really
important all right I'm going to bring
in dr. Jeffrey Gardere psychologist as
well into the conversation doctor thank
you we are trying
this technology with Skype and I know
you guys have been in and out so I
appreciate you hanging with us dr.
Gardere we were just talking about how
to tell your children and one thing that
dr. Compton Phillips was saying that you
can share with them that this won't
impact them as much but we do have some
positives in my own children's school
system our schools have been shut down
for a while
we have seen some positive testing in
kids as well they recover I mean they're
very resilient but but what else can we
tell our kids well I think it's
important that we ask our children where
they are with this whole situation what
is it that may be bothering them what is
it that they don't know about what
information do they know we have to meet
them exactly where they are instead of
lecturing to them and then we can begin
to explore with them in a realistic way
what is the best things that they need
to know empowerment strategies and how
we can come together as families and
community so this is something we have
to keep it as far as a positive mental
attitude as much as possible
dr. Gardere I live with a middle
schooler a teenager now and she says Oh
mom the world is overreacting I don't
know why everybody's so upset I've
always washed my hands why can't I go
back to school and of course I try to
fill in the gaps but you know me I have
a lot of information how much is too
much information for a child well to the
point of where they're zoning out or
they're not listening to you anymore you
really do want to capture their
attention so sometimes less is more and
something very simple we can say to them
is sweetheart this isn't just about you
it's not just about me it's about our
society it's about keeping everyone safe
so even though you may not get sick it's
possible that other people around you
can get sick especially if we don't take
care of ourselves so congratulations
that you wash your hands keep doing more
of that but then we need to do a little
bit more all right I want to talk about
something very disturbing that we saw
over the weekend and I'll start with
this president Trump and other officials
have been urging all of us to stop
hoarding groceries and other supplies is
the corona virus spreads what in our
psyche says
that we have to go out and buy 36 rolls
of toilet paper but leave all the soap
on the shelves yeah I think it's about
keeping up with the Joneses but in a
much more skewed way if we go into the
supermarket and we see that there's a
shelf that's empty or almost empty
then the feedback we get is oh we better
pick up the last amount or go someplace
else and get as much of that as possible
so this is a situation where it's
important that we just not follow the
crowd but follow our own hearts and
follow common sense the CDC tells us the
things that are important for us to have
and if they're not there how we can
improvise it but the important thing and
I know it's easier said than done is to
not to panic because panic will bring
out the worst in a we're seeing young
people fight over bottled water I mean
guess what
I mean it's terribly arrest but we've
got a we've got a model we've got a
model for our children the proper
behavior I like what you're saying we're
all in it together in that sense we can
model it maybe if they see some of us
staying calm that yes spread that's
great let that kindness and love spread
like contagion dr. Gardere dr. Compton
Phillips on the subject of psychology of
the virus spread I appreciate both of
you thank you we're gonna take a quick
break we'll be right back